thank you very much
nothing is more important than raising
awareness right
[Applause]
tonight we've hopefully brought to light
the impact that films have made and can
make on our lives as individuals and on
society as a whole
for the Academy
here are the films that made the
greatest impact this year
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to
parasite
[Applause]
[Applause]
parasite has six Academy Award
nominations and a is the first film that
in the English
-length picture winning four Oscars
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
I'm speechless
[Music]
we never imagined this to ever happen we
are so happy
[Applause]
I feel like a very opportune moment in
history is happening right now
foreign
[Applause]
I expressed my deepest gratitude and
respect for all the members of the
academy for making this decision thank
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi everybody
I really like to thank director pong
thank you
[Applause]
and I like everything about him his
smile
his crazy hair
the way he talks
the way he walks and especially the way
he directs
and what I really like about him is his
sense of humor and the fact is he can be
really
making fun of himself and he never takes
himself seriously thank you thank you
very much
and I'd like to thank everybody who's
been supporting parasite and who's been
working with parasite and who's been
loving parasite
and I'd like to thank my brother who's
been always supporting our building our
dreams
even when it looked Impossible Dream
thank you Jay I want to thank my brother
Jay and especially I really really
really want to thank our Korean film
audience our moviegoers who's been
really supporting all our movies
and never hesitated to give us
straightforward opinion on what they
feel like their movies
and that made us really never be able to
be complacent and keep pushing the
directors the creators keep pushing the
envelopes and without you our Korean
film audience we are not here thank you
very much
foreign